hello and welcome grand line wife who is
here now with a new review it won't all
be this calm and poetic review but haiku
are fun
do you like haiku give me a thumbs up if
so but do not worry there's no way I'm
keeping that up for an entire review I
can't threaten anyone I can't make any
Hisoka references I can't even troll
Liam if I'm speaking haiku so we're
definitely not sticking with it because
trolling Lee and truly add spice to my
life in a way no other thing does
it's how I show my love which is very
different to like murdering everyone
involved in decimating my people as my
eyes glow a fierce red he is looking at
you karateka
let's discuss episodes 40 and 41 shall
we
spoilers ahead episode 41 we return to
our good friend karateka for the start
of this episode and it's a quick battle
to find out the guy I thought had
sideburns like that dude from one pieces
eyebrows are they related is a plant not
a tree or bush or shrub but planted
there by the boss who is engaging in
nefarious kidnapping affairs to make
things more difficult for the people
involved could a picker and melody both
pick the other guy outs koala knots
koala hmm hang on what's her name that
that other chick kisses him turn him
into a dog like those he trains and
haiku cool dude basho decides to get
involved with a haiku making poetry cool
speaking of haiku music heart reader
oops
turns out she is a she interesting to
watch melody then I tend to jot down
notes for episodes as I watch them so I
can remember the things that stood out
to me it's why I make so many mistakes
often I'm only watching once to get my
first impression and then writing
whatever that is my notes about melody
are as follows strange rat person music
heart melody reader she not he it reads
like poetry I'll hang on I should
probably read it like poetry strange rad
person music harp melody reader
she not he it reads like poetry despite
the fact that they want my first
impressions of a character I suspect
based on the way she was introduced in
the insight she had will become quite
important to cropping unless she's
immediately killed in the next episode
who knows this series can be kind of
Game of Thrones II sometimes there'd
better be a more satisfying ending or
I'm going to buy a pie and throw it at
Liam's head Liam you have been warned
just saying the range of new characters
will probably become relevant very soon
as I suspect now cutter pick is going to
meet his friend
and these other people are going to keep
turning up in unsuspecting places melody
seems to have particular interest in
karateka though will she just trailer
him why is she interested in the
contract she very specifically asked for
this one what does she want she doesn't
want or seem to want caught up because I
I mean there's a part of me that expects
her to try to eat them with those teeth
I'm sure she's a beloved character but
she reminds me of all the Enid Blyton
knotty characters I read as a child and
so I expect her to be a toadstool person
rather than what seems like a really
insightful character who can hear the
rhythm of people's heartbeat and
probably manipulated once she connects
to it that's what I'm hoping
as for haiku men making a haiku cool
very expressive eyebrows doesn't see me
but then who could write haiku and be
evil myself excluded that is not that
I'm able this may be a lie I adore the
use of offensive art not offensive in
terms of offending people but offensive
rather than defensive the idea that you
can attack with poetry is really very
powerful as a concept it's highly
unusual so I very much appreciate it
especially since I've been known to
write poetry myself I also love that
there's every possibility that his power
has simply been unchallenged try saying
if you lie this will make you burst into
flames - someone with total conviction
and see if they actually do lie to you
genuinely and knowingly lie if you're
serious enough when you say it hey hey
look I'll try it on lamb and report back
hey Liam I have this piece of paper and
it says that if you lie to me you'll
burst into flames so here's my question
to you are there beanies
I meant are there beanies I can wear can
you make one can I have one
yay no flames for you they say the hot
chick kiss people make them like dogs
really awkward see I mentioned the
character made me uncomfortable last
time she still does so despite her
clever name since busy in French busy
means to with great abandon doesn't
matter let's talk about karateka and his
hardcore energy shift for this art now
that he's learned how to use and control
the power he wields I expect the Copic
is going to become incredibly dangerous
we returned to music to see how this
works
karappa kite is so angry he men's teams
just walking around in classical choral
music or his background as he has some
incredibly powerful thoughts in the dark
his eyes are red lines not even red does
that mean he's trying to control the
rage or that he's so angry that it's
bursting through despite his attempts to
hold it together what happens when that
dam breaks and why didn't we finish on
this image it would have been incredibly
powerful to end on Quora pika coming
into the realisation that he's the
closest he's ever been to his life goals
but instead we cut away to the farm
where Piggy's helping us tie up loose
ends with the help of his perfectly
spotlit [ __ ] why the [ __ ] who knows it
seems like the most out of character
situation to have occurred this
presumable nerd with sex dolls and
crumbs
I am also nerd I do not possess sex
dolls though I do have crumbs some
things translate well it's not just that
though there's a lot of jumping at the
end of this episode where I feel we
could have stayed with crapping I know
we need to bring everyone together but
it felt more like a distraction than
anything and we still haven't seen Leigh
audio bring on episode 41 let's see
where our students at episode 41 okay
Noli Oreos still but we're his killer
getting those fancy digs from really now
how does he have so many outfits given
he never walks around with them are
their magical pop out clothes pocket
clothes maybe they fold out maybe gods
carrying his luggage in that backpack he
has oh wait where's Kiowas bandage
satchel he had that right this entire
episode I'm not going to lie was very
confusing we were introduced to a range
of new people and I could see what was
happening on a grand scale each group is
coming together in York new city that
sounds weird
my head and in my mouth each group is
coming together in York News City and
that's good but the intricacies if the
whole thing really flew over my head on
a first watch and I admit I'm unlikely
to watch this episode again before this
my review goes to air but this is what I
got everyone is coincidentally after the
same thing they all want to be involved
in the auction and they're there with a
kawaii girl with neon hair if you will
because she can read fortunes
foretelling the deaths of people who
have paid her father to tell them how
the auctions going to go she has a
really creepy spirit guiding her hand
and there's something I love about that
and the fact that she doesn't know what
it is how it works or what the fortunes
are later she's being protected by
karateka who probably wants her and her
entire family dead because one of the
things they're after is the eyes of a
curta beyond that karappa kant's to kill
the phantom troupe which is really
convenient because they've decided to
steal check note everything everything
yes you heard me everything everything's
got it go how is this auction going to
go okay I have 30 1 billion 31 31 32 32
32 billion 37 37 43 43 do I hear oh okay
I'm sorry
there is nothing to sell but the eyes of
that kurta over there meanwhile go on
and kill I decide to have a LAN party
since when were there laptops in
internet cafes was that ever a thing did
I miss that and poor gone not being able
to access that really good-looking
beverage I felt bad for him greed Island
is looking more and more like it will be
its own Ark but something that propels
them through this one it's good
motivation it also turns out kill was
awful at stock markets and basic eBay
insight how he can be such a great
assassin have such good insight into
those lying then gets so easily scammed
out of like 350 million officer jenny is
very far beyond me
we've never been exposed to the ranks of
procurement so as with everything in
this episode it was a crash course in
terminology for this world overall I
struggled with it particularly given the
pace that was set for so long it's not
that I'm incapable of taking in that
information it's that until now I
haven't needed to or being reinforced
for doing so they've offered and re
offered information and it's often been
so immediately used that I haven't
soaked it all in it's like the
difference between asking a student to
turn up for and listen to a lecture and
read a textbook it feels like this
episode was a textbook and while there
will be a lot of interesting and
engaging information contained therein
in future the fact that two members of
the troupe decided to fight along the
way the fact that the troupe replaced
members as they go the fact that when
neon or her dad get mad at people they
get vacuumed are not as significant to
me as they otherwise would be I think
with a second or third watch once the
arc is over essentially there was so
much sensationalism in this episode that
I struggled to hold on to the important
information all of it was important and
all of it seemed key and so it lost the
sensational aspect I wanted from it yes
we got a huge number of names that I
feel like I'm supposed to remember and
I'm good at names and I'm good at with
people but even for me it's a difficult
mental situation to be in
my overall takeaway from the episode is
to simply watch wait and see as someone
who likes to be engaged in what I'm
watching either I need to take a step
back and just see how it goes as a whole
because there are going to be some
serious shenanigans or I'll experience
overwhelming anxiety as I go back and
write the names and functions of all the
characters in each faction involved in
this heist of complicated I'd likely
turn into that meme guy pointing at all
the link being crazy yeah him but with
my head what we know for certain is that
neon is not supposed to be at the
auction so somehow she will end up there
his Hawk is going to confuse the
situation because he's not on anyone's
team but his own we know he's not
actually a dedicated member of the
Phantom troops so that'll be an
interesting reveal for everyone else he
may well want to kill the head of the
troop given his sexy green moment there
was no swing but I expect one in future
he'll simply enjoy killing everyone
there and knowing gone is at the auction
I think he'll really enjoy that as much
as I enjoy trying to figure out how the
woman in the suit jacket the one in the
Phantom troop yeah her how she managed
to keep her boobs in the jacket and that
perky that's just not a thing just
saying oh and the lead bodyguard I feel
like he's going to double-cross them
despite the fact that he seems to
actively like neon I don't know I get
serious betrayal vibes from him
especially given he had a dude tied up
in a corner last episode we'll see how
we go with that everything is going to
get very messy over the next few
episodes as what I'm saying especially
since some of the groups involved know
about other groups involved and that's
not going to be an easy song at least
crap because happy I guess because he'll
get his chance at revenge as per his
creepy choral music I'm
that actually because you got the ending
I wanted him to have for episode 40 so
on that note let's end this episode on a
beautiful memory of karapa curbing the
most humane he will be for the rest of
the series i guess i expect him to be
neck deep in blood by the end not just
wading swimming and on that fun note
that's it from me if you've enjoyed this
detailed imagery and want to hear more
about beanies haiku and other stuff
click here if you want more click here
there's a subscribe button and a like
button and a dislike button and a
discord which doesn't so discord but hey
click it helped and rambling